seul président ce premier ministre
messieurs les ministres mesdames et
messieurs les députés les chers
collègues députés de france parmi les
députés de france
je vous souhaite du fond du coeur bonne
chance je vous souhaite
il faut du cas bonne chance parce que à
vos écoutant tout à l'heure je retrouver
les yeux de ces millions de nos
concitoyens qui m'ont parlé des mots
durant et dans lesquelles j'ai lu ce qui
ne fait plus étonnement aujourd'hui et
qui on fera je le regrette
hélas encore un peu à la fin du mois de
mai prochain jeu revu ses yeux emplis
danoise de peur c'est l'air qui m'ont
dit se sentir sans futur
il est ce thème partager ne plus savoir
au juste qui il était et j'ai vu dans le
même temps battre au fond de leur coeur
au plus tôt j'ai senti chez réside
l'espoir est de reconquérir ce que leurs
aïeux avaient versé dans la terre et que
vous avez évoquées ou cette sève qui
montait de la même terre pour ensemencer
je souhaite de tout coeur que vous
réussissiez monsieur le premier ministre
vous êtes une force et vous at-il
énergie je le sais mais il faut que vous
réussissiez parce que ce peuple rempli
d'espoir a besoin de réussir rapidement
sinon monsieur premier ministre je
crains que le temps qui nous reste
entre mai 2014 et mai 2017 ne soit pour
l'en
pour que notre pays puisse le vivre de
la manière républicaine et à la
française
comment vous l'avez si joliment illustré
dans vos dernières lignes que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et je crois savoir
retrouver à ce nom là un peu l'espoir
beaucoup d'espoir dans le coeur de nos
contemporains
parce que c'est la première fois que
dans ce monde qui bascule depuis 25 ans
sous nos cieux à ce monde sans repères
vous avez osé sans peur et sans reproche
reparler de frace reparler de france
chérie et reparler de l'histoire et d'un
projet je voudrais simplement dire
monsieur le premier ministre que je ne
partage malheureusement pas toutes les
la thérapie que vous nous avez proposé
et je voudrais vous exhorter s'il vous
plaît députés entre les députés à en
changer
je ne crois pas qu à valmy pas plus que
le général de gaulle vous avez cité ne
se soient mis au coeur de l'action a
changé la machinerie ou l'intendance du
pays
d'ailleurs il n'y en avait plus ils se
sont efforcés de relance et de
l'enthousiasmé de refaire confiance
dorais enraciner la france d'en bas est
de redonner un rôle et une confiance et
une perspective à ceux qui jour après
jour se battre parce que comme vous ils
partagent le même sentiment et je crois
que c'est vers eux qu'il faut sûr qu'il
faut s'appuyer
il faut le sortir de ses tourments des
changements de ces changements
incessants au niveau de notre
administration de notre organisation
ils n'y comprennent plus rien et vous
allez perdre beaucoup de temps et
beaucoup d'énergie et à changer les
régions et les départements et à faire
disparaître les communes et les cantons
et pendant ce temps vous ne serez pas
contre le grand capital
qui nous détruit jour après jour il faut
plutôt livré la bataille de
l'intelligence faire que ce vieux peuple
qui s'est toujours retrouvé dans les
grands moments de souffrance se re
aiment plaignent de sa propre
intelligence de son french flair
c'est là que nous sommes bons c'est là
que nous reprenons le goût de
l'entreprise
c'est là que nous nous libérons et c'est
là que nous étonnons et je préférerais
que lieu de monopoliser et de bloquer
les préfets dans leur préfecture avec
toute ces tous ces changements qui n'ont
pas de lieu d'être aujourd'hui dans une
période aussi grave pour notre pays que
vous libériez leur énergie pour il aux
herbes engagé le grand débat national
qui permettra au peuple et aux citoyens
de vous soutenir parce qu'il n'y a pas
de politique possible sans l'appui du
peuple
or le peuple n'est plus derrière nous ni
est derrière vous ni derrière pearson
dope
je vous souhaite de réussir mais je vous
en conjure
prenez votre temps plus tôt a expliqué
comment cela marche avec l'europe
mais si comme à une seconde se termine
comment on peut recommencer à
reconstruire nos entreprises comment on
peut reprendre notamment à notre
agriculture moribonde et comment on peut
relancer un grand projet d'instruction
publique comme le firent ferry écrivit
un moment où la france était plus
détruite encore qu'aujourd'hui de ce
premier ministre bonne chance mais
j'aimerais tant lui obtenir un peu comme
d'un député parmi les députés
un député venu de si loin merci monsieur